if you are smuggling a child then we
will prosecute you and that child may be
separated from you as required by law we
don't want to separate families but we
don't want families to come to the
border illegally every law enforcement
agency in this country separates parents
with children when they're arrested for
a crime there is no new policy this has
always been the policy there is real
bipartisan support for changing that I
would be open to changing that law but
the better law to change is to secure
our border
well immigration specifically about
immigrant children 1,500 of them the
headline said had been lost under the
Trump administration's adherence to this
policy AGHS putting out a statement
refuting that saying the assertion that
unaccompanied alien children USC's are
lost is completely false these children
are not lost their sponsors or usually
parents or family members in all cases
have been vetted for criminality and the
ability to provide for them simply did
not respond or could not be reached when
this voluntary call was made while there
are many possible reasons for this in
many cases sponsors cannot be reached
because they themselves are illegal
aliens and do not want to be reached by
federal authorities so what about this
issue specifically and where immigration
stands currently let's bring in our
panel join me here from the White House
Maher liason national political
correspondent of National Public Radio
and at the bureau Steve Hays editor in
chief for the Weekly Standard and match
slap contributor with the hill mark this
got a lot of attention got a lot of
attention and it has a lot of parts to
it first of all the idea these kids were
lost is not true on the other hand the
idea of separating kids and families
which was a policy by previous
administrations and as you just heard
the Trump administration made very clear
it wanted to continue it because it was
a deterrent don't bring your kids here
illegally cuz you're gonna get separated
from them all of a sudden it seems like
the White House felt that they didn't
want to be associated with this so they
decided to blame it on Democrats even
though it's a policy that they were
carrying throat Steve the
characterization of it really did depend
on what you were watching or reading as
far as these 1500 kids or that the
policy actually went back a couple of
administration's that's true but look
this really took off over the weekend
when you had former Obama speechwriter
Jon Favreau and others tweeting putting
this out they're putting out pictures of
migrant children in cages and hyping
this and saying it was outrageous
because it was the the Trump
administration doing this failing to
note of course that this had happened as
you as you say under previous
administration so that is something that
I think poured fuel on this proverbial
fire if you will but there's no question
that the Trump administration is trying
to take a tough stand on the illegal
border crossings which are up after
initially going down at the beginning of
the Trump administration by saying this
by making this part of their policy we
saw I think of the administration what
the power of presidential rhetoric what
the the power of administration rhetoric
did to decrease the numbers of people
trying to come across the border and I
think that that's their goal here and we
could debate whether this is the right
policy or not but they've said both John
Kelly as chief of staff and as you just
played Jeff Sessions as Attorney General
has made clear that they view this as an
effective deterrent man I always say the
disclaimer I tried to your wife works
for this administration and what do you
think the thought process is that behind
this this move are they pushing back
against bad news stories on this or is
there a strategy here that's developing
on the immigration brett-brett be
careful it's very hard to get into the
mind of your spouse but I would just
simply say that we got to focus on the
law and the only thing that the Trump
administration is doing differently than
the Obama administration when it comes
to these people with unaccompanied
minors is they are following the law it
is a criminal violation for an adult to
cross our border illegally the question
is what do you do with the kids
here's the real kicker the kids the
7,600 kids are some or someone that
we're talking about this population
almost all of them will stay in America
for as long as they
let's get that let's have that set in
this we said we only sent home something
like five kids last year if an
unaccompanied monitor gets to our border
it is taken into this process they stay
in America and most of them who are
given a place to stay temporarily while
supposedly they're gonna have a hearing
in the first thirty days are given to
relatives who are themselves here
illegally
so when Democrats say that the Trump
administration lost 1500 kids maras
right that's not accurate
we've actually lost 20 million people
and those 20 million people are bringing
in more relatives to the border this is
why no matter whether you build a wall
or not we have a problem every day at
the border that there's all these
loopholes that allow you to jump in line
hopscotch online to be able to be in
America for as long as you want to be
Morrow I mean the key point here is that
the reason the lost source story is not
accurate is because they were calling
these sponsors and frankly they just
didn't answer they just don't know if
they don't their kids aren't there if
they're someplace else
right that doesn't count as lost meaning
they don't know where they are they
didn't return a phone call to me the
interesting thing is the Trump
administration wanted to publicize this
you had John Kelly Jeff Sessions saying
we're gonna separate these kids as the
law says we should so don't bring them
all of a sudden it sounds like they feel
that they want to blame that separation
but I'm Democrat but do you think that
this is a political issue is one that is
powerful for Democrats as they head to
the mid show they want to say the Trump
administration is heartless and they're
separating kids even though Obama did
the same thing but what's so interesting
to me is Donald Trump does have a soft
spot in the administer the immigration
debate daca kids he's often said that he
loves them he wants to treat them with
great heart he clearly doesn't want to
be on the wrong side of this story and
seem like he's the guy separating Kay
and Steve last word the thought about
immigration as a legislative issue as we
head towards the midterms now well
that's easy bread I can easily predict
what's gonna happen okay now look no but
nobody knows nobody knows I mean in the
short term this is a Republican
challenge because Republicans have
controlled the house and there's not
consensus on how they should proceed in
the house you have more restriction Asst
legislation that conservatives have been
pushing for a long time you also have
moves by the moderates and
days to try to get their legislation
surfaced and there's disagreement among
Republicans longer term the question is
whether I think Democrats will agree to
fund something like a border wall that
Donald Trump is saying that he wants